nous allons faire un tour du monde sans
escale sans carburant fossile et sans
émission de CO2
un tour du monde en 20 jours on va
parcourir à peu près 40 000 km à une
altitude de 6000 m et ce tour du monde
aura comme équipage que des pilotes de
renom nous aurons Bertrand Piccard qui
est Monsieur solarin pulse nous aurons
Michel Tonini qui est un ancien
astronaute et Dorine Bonneton qui est la
première femme pilote de voltige
handicapé
l'enveloppe du redirigeable et recouvert
de 4800 mètres carrés de voile solaire
qui vont produire de l'énergie pour la
journée pour faire tourner les moteurs
électriques le complément d'énergie qui
n'aura pas été utilisé va être stockée
dans des batteries et pour la nuit nous
allons faire appel à des piles à
combustibles pour pouvoir donc voler 24
heures sur 24
[Musique]
ce qui est difficile c'est le sens
escale si on peut dire c'est en fait de
faire ce tour du monde avec assez
d'énergie pour ne pas avoir à se poser
donc nous avons donc fait pas mal
d'études de recherche développement pour
voir quel était le mix énergétique qui
nous permettait de pouvoir accomplir
cette mission
on n'est pas là pour remplacer les
avions on offre une nouvelle mobilité
c'est complémentaire aux avions c'est
une mobilité qui est décarbonée en fait
si vous voulez on fait un tour du monde
certes c'est un exploit technologique
c'est un exploit humain mais la finalité
c'est justement l'industrialisation de
ces dirigeables
nous adressons un certain nombre de
marché entre autres le marché du
tourisme éco-responsable le deuxième
marché c'est la surveillance civile
militaire le troisième marché ça peut
être la logistique logistique le
transport de charges lourdes un autre
aspect aussi qui est le support donc
humanitaire pour tout ce qui est
catastrophe naturelle où on peut
intervenir surtout
rapidement pour dispatcher l'aide
humanitaire quand il y a plus
d'infrastructures au sol
[Musique]